citizens of the reject Nation we are here
for the penultimate episode of The Last of
Us season one I'm not prepared but I'm so
excited joining me once again in the hot seat
is Tara Erickson Tara how you doing today
I'm good guys I got a cool t-shirt on yeah
roller skate Club sound off in the comments
for Tara's drip in fact leave a like for Tara's
drip and why don't you go ahead before you
do anything else subscribe and ring that Bell
ring the bell oh we need a super
and I'm glad that you're getting your flowers
for that as well check out La eats and drinks
which is Tara's brand new food experience
on the web for you guys eating and drinking
my way through Los Angeles and recording at
all oh that's right don't miss a single moment
get those tasty morsels we appreciate you
guys for not spoiling this experience for
us if you want to get the full-on gamer perspective
go and check out Greg and Andrew's Last of
Us reactions and as well if you want to enjoy
all of our reactions uncut with everything
that doesn't make these highlight reels come
on over to patreon.com the real rejects where
you can sync up with your own copy enjoy the
full experience and uh last but not least
guys uh we got a new Last of Us inspired t-shirt
the Greg and the Zero edition team put together
and if you want one they're available now
in the real rejects shopzeroedition.com store
got beanies and hoodies and all sorts of fun
stuff over there Tara did I forget anything
is there anything you want to tell the people
no except I would like that t-shirt all right
well you're an extra large now here we go
foreign
[Music] you get this song down yet John I'm
working on it it's it's actually not as complicated
as you would imagine it's just about getting
the mood and the timing right so maybe by
the finale episode I'll have a little some
some for you guys yeah you better have a Vibe
going on because if I'm gonna wear all yellow
you know to try to virus it up do that terrafungus
yeah God now I have to go buy all yellow clothing
just glue some buttered lettuce to your face
I really dug my own grave Revelation 21 and
I saw a new Heaven and a new Earth it's Los
Angeles this week and I heard a great voice
out of Heaven saying behold the Tabernacle
of God Church in a steakhouse I do not mind
that
from their eyes
what God get in there yeah where's the get
in there guys tears coming down they're not
being wiped
he shall provide and God will wipe away all
tears from their eyes neither will there be
any more pain do you know what that means
there's a pop quiz coming up are you sure
oh the ground is too cold to dig we'll bury
your father in the spring
oh stank the cutlets of Christ finally busts
out the stake at least here in winter like
his body will be perfectly preserved until
the spring true is it probably like an ice
cube out there how much do we have left the
hotel on rations maybe a week two at best
uh I sensed doubt in there you haven't lost
faith in you David you're just scared not
from them from you I still believe it's been
uh last six months have been hurt but I need
to know you're with me believe better now
go get our guns we're going hunting
foreign
falls in the pile of guns they all go off
and uh feel free to Enlighten and or roast
us for that buddy boy casting there [Music]
oh wake him up with some jerky smell a jerky
always gets me up in the morning put it right
under his nose
[Music]
gonna try to go hunt now is she going to run
into those people out there I saw her look
okay yeah we see you
wow dang the apocalypse seems so peaceful
when you're not being attacked by butter lettuce
heads
[Music] but it's so cute that you just keep
it as a pet oh oh Ellie okay
frostbite God that would hurt so bad
oh okay now that's a prize
oh you got this come on you got it girl
kill shot please oh no no no kill him no I
hate it I hate it no
[Music] take her thing she already started
on it feel it God sent us this wounded deer
the venison of Christ
little senior
yeah you think we can just take it quickly
whoever shot it's probably nearby damn
oh heck yeah
now yeah yeah girl get it
now help me carry this back to Joel and he
sudden moves that put one right between your
eyes did all for buddy boy my name is David
this is my friend James we're from a larger
group women children and we're all very very
hungry I'm from a large group too also hungry
not with biblical names what do you need we
have boots medicine back in our village here
buddy boy can go get it talked to Howard he's
got a case with some penicillin bring back
two bottles and a syringe it's not code James
as I said come on man come on man you're gonna
get half the deerless good scoot buddy boy
yeah buddy boy buddy man he's like well in
John chapter five yeah we gotta really King
here in the situation with your dad's gun
you the one that's sick that's why you're
out here on your own
smart it's a Four Mile round trip back to
our settlement it's gonna be a while before
James gets back we should take shelter bring
him with us oh boy oh jeez
I'm just glad he's dead and not in pain you're
the leader yes some weird cult thing well
you sort of kind of got me there I am a preacher
but just pretty standard bible stuff prefer
the term congregation and as we wandered we
picked up new people along the way until we
ended up here oh you look how to run out sooner
or later I believe everything happens for
a reason so I sent four of our people to a
nearby town to to scavenge what they could
only three of them came back and the one that
didn't was a father he had a daughter just
like you and her dad was taken from her but
we were able to eat him he was murdered by
this crazy man that crazy man was traveling
with a little girl oh no
everything happens for a reason oh James lower
the gun whoa dude [__] so weird dicey
oh my goodness did you bring the medicine
yeah but throw it to her David you want to
eat or you want to get Vengeance I would rather
eat back away
you won't survive for long out there I can
protect you get that whole deer though dang
it yeah so you're just gonna let it get away
oh I have a feeling he has a different plan
in mind Let Jesus Take the Wheel he'll he'll
find some fitting retribution for this
Joe where the [__] do I put this
oh good right little thing I think it's like
in the arms okay
okay I hope you got the dosage right as well
I have some liver and onions tonight yum yum
what is it
again dude can you find us like an elk or
something yes we found a girl who was with
the man who took Alex from us when the Sun
rises I'll lead a group out to pick up her
Trail won't be hard to find in the snow and
we'll bring that man to justice of course
you will kill both of them
oh okay nope nope back to layers like what's
this guy's deal okay it's way too reasonable
up front it's a bit culty now I know you think
you don't have a father anymore but the truth
is Hannah you will always have a father and
you will show him respect when he's speaking
it's everyone's Daddy oh yeah who'd you lose
who are you trying to fill a void with all
these people with he lost his Steakhouse man
[Music]
the sound design in this scene a lot of people
in a studio just think clanking props to the
Foley team [Music]
killing an Ellie becoming RN
[Music] oh two-horse garage I'm gonna go and
cover your truck oh no
uh oh Darcy
is that a bird of prey symbolism hmm
birds of death shite now you know kid
yep good good good this man's not already
dead he's dangerous about the girl if we leave
her out here she'll die yeah maybe that's
God's will
talk to me about cat's will I decide God's
will keep your mouth shut buddy boy [Laughter]
Ellie you're gonna have to like do some [__]
oh
[Music] did anybody makes it down here you
can kill them you got it
what an interesting presence for him this
episode
oh man
oh bad feeling bad feeling I'm so scared right
now uh the anxiety
oh [__] oh okay no no don't shoot the
horse or her okay alive [Music] oh boy
yes Ride Like the Wind
if you want him come and claim him God please
don't be a good shot buddy boy no no oh no
no the Horrors I don't like it are they gonna
eat that horse now they better
[Music] what
father says no you all got some Penance to
do now two of you with me drag the horse the
rest of you stay here go door to door start
knocking you so hungry from vengeance deliver
it it's a cult it's a cult cult
[Music]
that's right wake up come on get up
hope you're good at knife throwing or playing
dead
yes
oh my God I'm still so worried
[Music]
I have teeth
[Music] [Laughter] oh
no thank you
I started worrying you wouldn't wake up why
am I in a cage you're a dangerous person you've
certainly proven that you can't survive on
your own no one can I'm not on my own that
part of your life it's ending and what I'm
offering you is a beginning but if you can't
find a way to trust me then yes you are alone
only I can help you have to remember Ellie
he owned a steakhouse that's right that's
right trust the Outback man trust Ruth's Chris
over here
[Music]
the Beards on this crew are amazing oh [__]
[Laughter] yes that was nice bait good job
Joel he carried him all the way out there
up the stairs leave him alone oh you're next
please I don't know any girl
yeah I can't help you you focused
where
ah the town
Silver Lake this is Silver Lake I think so
I live there not for long it's a resort a
resort
Where We Are the resort is oh that's great
if he's actually going to spot your buddy
points too
oh man go ask him he'll tell you I'm not lying
oh
[Music]
you [__] you I ain't telling you [__]
it's okay no I believe him no
wow
whoa cold but also a full effective hand killer
that was that was hard
don't trust the food [Applause]
foreign [Music]
[Laughter]
I'd rather not if
you want to judge me judge you [Music] [Laughter]
so what was I supposed to do let them starve
yeah maybe you don't believe that I don't
think your friend would either didn't he take
another man's life to save yours he was defending
himself keep Joel's name out of your mouth
yeah you see a lot so do I and you know what
I see when I look at you me you have a violent
heart and I should know because I do too I've
always had a violent heart but then the world
ended and I was shown the truth now my cordyceps
sure it feeds and protects its children and
it secures its future with violence if it
must that's true why are you telling me all
of this I'm a Shepherd surrounded by sheep
and all I want is an equal [Laughter] what
about my friend I can tell the others to stop
looking for him they'll spare him if he leaves
us in peace they will just let him go they
do what I tell them to do they follow me yeah
for how long though too late they're already
dead buddy do you think of what we could do
together we'd make this place perfect imagine
the life we could give them
Joel just needs to come in now be my daughter
wife no what no no no no no no
hahaha you look Ed always no dang it ugh Ally
what tell them that Ellie is a little girl
who broke here yes how did you put it tiny
little pieces oh wow
see you at the steakhouse [Music]
buddy oh God gotta find grogu man come on
ding Jaren
[Music] it's good survival horror
oh the horse right no
oh yeah oh yeah yup yup yup oh God neat freezers
open okay all right ugh
oh geez
shut up oh whoa [Music] you had your chance
oh no and no sorry sorry roll up my sleeve
look at it
oh
of course
what did you say [Music] there's a reason
oh now she will return by now this isn't real
that looks pretty she's still transmit [Music]
no Jesus
oh
oh man oh my goodness where is everybody not
that I'm complaining foreign
sorry buddy boy we're eating good tonight
it's the
cult [Music] oh they're busy preparing some
Kool-Aid
yeah either stay Save The Steakhouse or go
kill Ellie save the steakhouse yeah No Way
Out Ellie the doors are locked and I have
the keys Ellie you better save your Steakhouse
buddy come on how are you gonna cook up all
those dead bodies I know
think of the mouths to feed what's the secret
or are you just that special yep she is no
one likes being humiliated Ellie you don't
know how good I am what you don't know what
I could have given you just let me oh I wonder
what this guy's like on a date I've decided
you do need a father so I'm gonna keep you
and I'm gonna teach you oh [Music]
okay ah
wow goodness no I thought you already knew
the fighting is a part I like the most oh
God damn it there's no fear in love oh
as many times as it takes yes laughs yup yup
yup yup
yes yes get your catharsis girl take that
ax and get the hell out of there how many
swags was that too jeez not enough that's
probably just mush oh no the ax you guys know
how I feel about weapons being left behind
take the freaking ax or fashion yourself a
new one oh thank God [Laughter] [Music]
oh okay
it's okay baby girl oh
look at you oh
oh wow wow [Music]
that somebody in these episodes and with them
walking off into the business all right oh
okay I need a I need a breather oh
well yeah that was a hilarious and heartwarming
episode
that gave me faith in the future of humanity
what you think Tara what'd you think of uh
episode eight oh okay oh man yeah um well
I'll just say the first thought I mean that's
so sweet the end it made me cry but I like
that my assumption was Joel is gonna pop in
and save her and I like that she we have now
just seen how much she has learned from Joel
and just how strong she is as a human that
she didn't need it she saved herself and Joel
was there obviously to take her at the end
which was nice but um I like that we didn't
I mean of course he killed those guys before
and then got to her but I'm just saying at
the end I really liked how she did The Killing
yeah yeah and then it wasn't like Joel coming
in and shooting that guy I'm like no I hope
you die by her ax in her hands yeah totally
100 and I do quickly want to shout out Troy
Baker because yeah that in the moment uh I'm
sure the comments have filled up already and
I appreciate you guys for for hipping us because
yeah I wouldn't have picked it up in the moment
in fact this experience Greg sent me like
a potential thumb for his reaction with Andrew
and he was like do you recognize this actor
and I was like well that's buddy boy it's
James but uh I I don't know who the actor
is and then it's slowly like an echo started
to come back to me and then he was like it's
Troy Baker and I was like oh oh so you know
he must have greater importance and sure enough
you know there's your voice of Joel right
there which is really cool given what uh the
you know dynamics of the episode had him ultimately
have to do in certain contexts that's a name
I have become aware of over the years due
to various animated projects and especially
going through the DC animated stuff with koi
recently I've seen his name pop up a lot there
as he's been Batman and Joker and various
other characters and yeah just the way that
they have shown love to those actors who helped
bring these iconic characters that people
love so much from the game to life and giving
them roles I mean especially him you know
the guy who played Tommy was a little more
of a side character but especially Troy Baker
here I thought left a real big impression
and did a great job you know with just the
tension and the conflict within that character
of James um and alongside Scott Shepard too
uh as David really great back and forth and
just that sense of History they have with
each other I haven't done a ton of excess
reading into parallels with the game and and
you know diving too deep into any number of
details that could lead to spoilers and whatever
else you want to keep these fresh so yeah
you can Enlighten us to any other pertinent
info about him as it pertains to The Last
of Us in the comments but I did want to make
sure we at least touched on that because uh
yeah in the moment and and we were talking
during the credits and stuff like that so
I just didn't catch it and uh and yeah now
I will not forget Troy Baker's face but uh
but this is the experience that taught it
to me so so yeah thanks for helping us though
or roasting us or both back to the review
it's fascinating because they give you so
many things to be suspicious of that do kind
of ultimately come true but I I liked yeah
the way they drew this impossible seeming
scenario and then found their way out of it
it like you said in that way where it is her
doing most of the heavy lifting for herself
and it's like yeah Joel is able to you know
get back up on his feet but he's not just
like full adrenaline you know kicking ass
and just moving like it's nothing and like
if there's one thing I did wonder about and
they do it I think a fine enough job in the
dialogue of basically addressing that yeah
like most of these people who live here they're
not violent they need somebody to lead them
they're probably very scared and so even though
part of me was like where is everybody doing
all of this yeah uh having you know the pastor
and Buddy Boy uh David and James I think their
names were having them as your sort of main
forces uh in the camp and then having all
those other guys out looking for Joel and
everything like that like it seemed at least
geographically like okay they put all their
kind of uh fight and ready people on both
of these sides of this Mission so so geographically
that made sense but yeah just having this
debate and having this unfolding of this guy's
character I thought was really fascinating
whoever that actor is uh who played what is
his name I think it was David uh he just did
such a great job and it's he endears or at
least me he endeared me and I thought they
did a great sort of representation of the
peeling back of the layers because at first
you're like okay I see how we're on two sides
of a conflict and while we probably can't
fully make this amicable you don't seem like
that bad of a guy and I get the position that
you're in but sure enough the deeper you get
into the episode and the more desperate circumstances
become for him in particular you start to
see all the layers peeled back and yeah like
this is you know like the worst guy
oh and it's funny like I'm curious to know
what people think because on the one hand
like you know he's presented as a religious
leader and so part of you is like okay it
had to go down this route I guess not only
is he yeah you know more of a cult leader
in this here and now than he is truly like
a pastor or a savior even though he comes
across very much that way but then yeah he's
got the violence and he's also got the you
know inappropriate urges like that whole scene
I thought was great in the cage for multiple
reasons but partly it just becomes so uncomfortable
when you're like I can't tell if this is just
a trust building thing or if he really is
implying like no you'll be my girl wife and
we will lead this together with you subtle
grooming yeah and it's like ah like it's I
thought they earned it really well because
on the one hand you know you I I think that's
a place that you would naturally if you want
to make a twisted Pastor character I feel
like that's one of the places you directly
go um but I thought the way they portrayed
it and the way that actor portrayed it um
just lent a lot of credence to it it was really
engrossing that like especially because you
couldn't tell when he's like we don't kill
like that girl who's like kill him and then
he's like like killing's wrong but really
when you think back on it when he's like alive
you're like oh because you want to keep her
for yourself probably yeah you want somebody
who isn't already entangled with the rest
of the game the rest of the group develop
this new Dynamic with you can lock her in
a cage do some slight grooming yeah yeah the
eater if it doesn't sort of right which which
that too I I loved the way they I love the
way they used and didn't use Music throughout
this because when they have that first like
dinner scene where everyone's just chowing
down and all the sounds of of Cutlery and
eating and you're just sitting here in this
situation you're again I think designed to
think there's got to be people in there if
they're having a food scarcity there has to
be some kind of Donner Party parallel you
know we gotta eat people and uh and I love
the way they held on to that until the very
end and then Ellie sees the because you know
she's in the cage and just the visual cues
let you in on the idea of like good kind of
kitchen any room for to have this cage yeah
and then you see the ear and all that and
uh and I like the way they handled that too
it's like it's one of those conclusions that
I think is pretty easy to get to in a scenario
like this but I thought they represented it
with a lot of credence to make it believable
and not feel contrived yeah it also came off
very culty in the episode when they bring
in the the deer or the elk or whatever it
was it was a deer right whatever they bring
it in and everyone is so venison everyone
is so silent it's so not it is just him talking
and leading in the beginning one person says
a thing and he is like absolutely not having
it and then when they bring it you you assume
that they would be excited or happy and that's
when you really know like Uh something's like
off here something yeah this whole place like
if you talk you're probably yeah exactly and
like he smacks that girl upside the face and
everybody seems very sort of nobody stands
up like there are dudes in that room Not Just
Women and Children right there's other guys
there that could be like yo man like we shouldn't
be doing this and I'm like oh does that mean
that you and your lackeys they all have guns
and nobody else does and you're lackeys will
like shoot anybody who stands up to you because
like now we're talking like church Mafia sure
no and it makes you wonder like it gives you
a lot to them think about like yeah is this
guy taking in people who are just docile and
only the ones who are inclined to believe
him like do accidents befall or do they you
know take out people who just aren't with
you know their version of the program or or
his version of how this is supposed to go
and uh and to his whole story about like I
love that that flip of the inspiration of
like I found God after the apocalypse and
then realizing later on that no you probably
didn't you just probably were somebody in
your previous Life as a teacher or whatever
a math teacher or whatever he was who probably
you know felt beholden to so many systems
and probably felt very small and now you've
found he says that whole thing about you're
like me you're a leader you know you you know
what people need and you know how to you know
persuade and protect people and all that stuff
and and he talks about like I got these people
to look out for they love me you know they
look up to me and you could tell he probably
you know has lived a life where he would have
always wanted that level of status and Grandeur
and now he's finally able to achieve it and
also feed his worst inclinations along the
way yeah I feel like he's also smart enough
to go what's the biggest Ploy I can use to
gather a group of people and make them feel
safe sure religion Bible let's just like become
this thing that most people are like in when
you're close to death most people like I didn't
press started praying right you're like I
was in a plane crash it's going down you're
like say in your prayers so it's it's like
oh yeah he's probably smart enough to use
that as his Ploy yeah yeah totally I found
God no you you just became a God yeah uh but
but yeah like so many great like so many great
characterizations that I think really help
the the tropier aspects of you know the things
there are nuts and bolts of what happens here
that we've seen before but I thought that
they really well realized both the character
sides of that and just the geography again
like the way that they split the two groups
up and they've got you know these guys hunting
Joel and them taking Ellie back like they
really draw this impossible feeling situation
and then when Ellie you know the escalation
of Ellie making these moves against these
people and sort of never relenting on her
instincts of distrust for them uh like when
she finally has him cornered and she's just
beating him with that Cleaver like you really
feel all that rage and pain and anguish come
out both for this situation but probably just
all of what's been pent up up until now you
know and and for as much as Ellie has been
sort of uh carefully guided and handled in
terms of like weapons and when and how to
use them like this was just full-on just like
let it all out girl and I really felt for
her in those moments and and then when Joel
comes back at the very end like I think we
both got got teary-eyed because you just feel
the sort of desperate relief that it's like
a very specific life moment that I feel like
most everybody has at some point but they're
rare that's sort of like I am just overcome
right now and I'm not even fully aware of
my surroundings and then you sort of Clap
into somebody close a warm you know comforting
figure and then in a different way it all
comes out then then the you know then the
vulnerability you know overflows rather than
the rage yeah and uh and I thought that was
kind of beautifully handled there yeah I mean
up until that point she Ellie was always just
a strong snarky smart girl who could handle
herself and dealt with the independence of
Joel and she had that same Independence but
at that moment she was just a little girl
yeah needed Joel in that moment and you know
he is now like her actual father figure right
he he is now a foundation for her like a rock
and he has always been there and in that moment
it was like you just saw Ellie is like oh
she's a kid but we've we haven't seen that
I don't even think from the top I think it's
like now in episode eight we've seen her in
that moment just in that moment after that
you're like she's a kid you know and she needed
she needed like a hug from uh uh like a family
member because Joel is like family now whether
they say it out loud or not and I think that's
why I found it so touching you just finally
go oh yeah Ellie's a badass but like she's
still a kid sure and like that's a great point
because especially in this episode so much
of it is like the exact opposite like my my
companion my parental figure my friend is
completely out of commission I gotta figure
out everything I gotta hold up these guys
and make sure I get out of this situation
I gotta find us some food I gotta find us
medicine I gotta figure out where and how
to administer the medicine all on my own and
then yeah get put in the cage almost eaten
it's like it's it's way more than anybody
should ever have to deal with but that also
on the heels of everything else you know it's
like even in the mall with Riley she's not
fully abled there there are moments and glimpses
where they get to forget about things and
just have fun and be kids but this was a different
version this was yeah like the most vulnerable
the just I need a hug please consult me this
is too much to handle right yeah yeah yeah
and uh and two I mean I love I love the way
they've geographed the time too because you
know you've got Joel basically on his back
for since two episodes ago through the last
episode up until here and so they made like
a really nice gradual uh just you know re
just getting him back on his feet was a nice
gradual process that I thought was pretty
tangible and then when he's got those two
guys it's like yeah Joel seems better equipped
in these situations than these guys probably
are despite the fact that they are in perfectly
good health so even there I was pretty pretty
easily able to suspend that disbelief and
then he's got that guy with the knife and
he's like point on the map and he does the
kind of the same thing as he did with the
couple from a few episodes ago the the Native
American couple where he's like you know you
tell me where and then you tell me where and
if they don't match and you know obviously
it plays out different here but uh I believe
him uh but yeah like really well designed
designed episode in terms of both what it
does for Joel and Ellie and as well as getting
a yet another glimpse into what how certain
people will respond what life might be like
you know in this situation yeah because we
thought before like three episodes ago that
I was like oh the what are you called they
weren't the fireflies over that were they
the fire no in that group that I'm like she's
she's the cult leader they were just a group
that was weird they weren't a cult this is
a cult no in like an apocalypse there's gonna
be there's gonna be some Cults and now we
got to one where they're eating people and
he's just like slapping anybody who talks
yeah he is clearly status one of this cult
yeah people like I love again the way that
they let you bounce off of those things because
at first you're just like oh these people
are just Meek and and tired and cold but also
probably no they're also probably afraid to
speak up to this guy yeah like there's probably
a lot of like buried pushed down fear amongst
these people and so I wonder how they're gonna
fare now that they don't have any of their
heavyweights I just find it so odd that if
I was in that group and obviously he had to
build trust to get their loyalty meaning he
couldn't be slapping him around right away
right so but then once you see that he does
do that and they're like they're all just
seemed so Meek I'm like it's so crazy to me
that they're not holding a meeting to start
a riot I would like steal a weapon in the
middle of the night and just shoot him and
all of his buddy boys uh and be like I'm gonna
lead it now I'm nice let's go get food like
I I find it so odd I know that it's proud
it's very difficult and you're afraid to lose
your life but I'm always like man you got
it come on now like start a riot and kill
the bad got the numbers yeah you have the
numbers you know and it makes you like like
this is one of those episodes that gives you
so many different directions to wonder in
because yeah that I'm like what how much do
these people know about this guy and what
is WE peer in on what appears to be like the
average day here but yeah like you could every
time we visit a new pocket you're like yeah
there's a whole life happening here you could
do a whole show just about this if you wanted
to I mean you know not that I'm saying that
should happen obviously the Joel and Ellie
story is part of the bread and butter that
holds this all together but there's yeah just
so much interesting potential to these things
and and you know the way they realize this
character like yeah he is pretty villainous
by the end especially this whole like this
is my favorite part the struggle but you know
there are elements of the character at times
that aren't 100 that and that's the interesting
drama that whole thing about like cordyceps
isn't evil cordyceps is just doing its natural
thing and it's just perpetuating itself protecting
its own it's it's you know ensuring the longevity
of its species which you know is an interesting
thing to acknowledge because yeah it is just
sort of a force of nature that that happens
and I love the use of the bite too and making
us wonder about that because I don't think
we've ever had that we have like where it's
like somebody right and do they become infected
yeah yeah I was like oh wait is he going to
like if we're with him long enough is he going
to turn because she lives with that inside
of her right I don't know who knows yeah I
hope he doesn't because then he'd still be
around sure like I just just please let him
be oh and it's a cool counterweight too because
she does the thing with uh uh what was the
little boy Sam she she tries to apply her
blood as a cure and then she tries to use
it the opposite direction here and I like
that we don't kind of have a full we don't
know yeah it's gonna yeah which direction
that goes in and it's you gotta be not that
easy either way right but he also I mean if
he turned into a butter lettuce head he would
just be it would be all falling off I mean
she chopped him up good she chopped him up
real good he would just be he'd be salad really
honestly he's the chop sound yeah for sure
he's a chopped salad nobody wants to eat him
though even though they're they're used to
eating people oh thanks oh God yeah not you
buddy and the way they they handled that I
mean yeah you like you know in that that dinner
scene you're able to hone in and be like I
don't know man yeah I don't know and then
and then when they reveal it they don't go
full boring to just like cannibal land but
it's enough it's like you see the bodies hanging
up in there clandestine meat freezer and you
see the the someone's got to clean up the
ears man yeah somebody's gonna clean up the
kill floor oh gnarly but yeah this was this
was a really fascinating episode and really
well handled really interesting drama Great
Performances across the board especially from
I mean from Bella Ramsey especially Pedro
Pascal of course but also the guest cast great
use of Music great use of atmosphere you really
feel the chill and the cold of everything
and and even the tension of the fire at the
end him kind of looking him of like which
which of these do I focus on and do I just
let this room burn for my own selfish desire
or do I take care of the greater good arguably
and douse this fire and make it so that we
still have a dining hall to eat people in
I don't know this is one of those episodes
where I think you could go on forever and
ever talking about it but uh but yeah this
was this was great Bravo and I cannot wait
to see what the finale holds because jeez
yeah so I'm sad yeah I don't want it to be
over yeah me neither R.I.P their horse uh
R.I.P that deer and uh and yeah you got anything
else before we hit the road
well guys leave a like leave a comment with
your thoughts on the episode uh are you excited
for the end of the season are you sad that
we'll have to wait uh for another keeping
helping of The Last of Us leave any of your
thoughts down below that aren't spoilerific
because obviously you get the point and uh
last but not least let's let's do a pitch
Gabriel if this episode could have used anything
it was a guardian angel Gabriel haha you see
what I did there religious episode religious
shout out Gabriel though I mean you are such
a lovely and kind Presence at our patreon
you are the pastor I would follow during the
apocalypse you know if you made some kind
of realization in your life you're like you
know what I need a flock I need to extol my
virtues to the people I would be like yes
please fill my brain I don't want to think
for myself anymore I'm tired of doing that
that's why I do most days it's hard it's confusing
just tell me what to think Gabriel yeah um
the only thing I think I would say to you
is just to keep your pledge indefinitely forever
uh and uh otherwise we will not follow absolutely
not no that's that's the price you know we
everybody has a price and this is ours yeah
so uh you know the may the Lord be with you
and also with you and uh and also with you
is that how it goes I have to say it back
right everybody in church goes down a chain
and they're like also with you also with you
everybody by the end of the ceremony or the
service you know has had all four hours yeah
okay yeah that takes up most of it yeah there's
like a couple scriptures a little bit of a
sermon we pass out the YouTubers but mostly
it's people shaking hands feeling like also
with the news you don't want to leave anybody
out people pleasing a church okay I get it
anyway Gabriel thanks for joining us and we'll
catch you next month love you buddy foreign
[Music]